From hostile deserts to loan the islands and the highest mountains,
wherever there is space to expand into humans do so.
So it's hardly surprising that we're already making preparations to set foot on
Mars and to create the first permanent colony outside of earth.
Maybe even terraforming other planets and turn it into a second,
the blue home,
but wait,
before we can get to the nice future staff,
we first have to complete the second phase of colonization that creating a
semipermanent outpost to prepare the ground for a larger human presence,
but doing so we'll beat gruesome.
Yeah.
Even for an expansionist species like us,
Mars is extreme at first glance,
Mars seems for me.
Yeah.
The ice caps,
large valleys,
liquid water under its surface and a day barely longer than earth.
The ideal place for us to go,
unfortunately,
Mars is actually a cold radio active desert where the ground is poisonous and
breathing is impossible.
Mars is awful.
You almost certainly don't want to go there.
The pioneer's doing the hard work on Mars,
we'll have an intensely stressful life filled with incredibly challenging
problems.
Never encountered before,
but there are plenty of people willing to do that work and we have the
technology to enable them to do it.
For this video,
we will assume they have been prior missions to Mars to scout out a good pace
for an outpost store,
resources and equipment,
and that there's already a moon base that serves as a hub for Mars missions.
The first major challenge for our outpost is the fact that Mars is very energy.
Paul,
because of its distance from the sun,
solar power is only 40% as effective as on earth,
but even this weekend,
some nice is often obscured for days by enormous dust storms.
Solar power alone will probably not be enough.
Alternatives such as wind power and geothermal energy are also unfeasible as
there's hardly any atmosphere and Mars is interior is much too cold.
Initially,
nuclear technology might be the only option.
Since Mars doesn't have it easily accessible radioactive elements,
the nuclear fuel needs to come from Earth along with the reactor.
If we do set it up,
it could power how small outpost for the first few years.
Unfortunately all that energy wouldn't be very useful if we can't breathe.
Mars's atmosphere is only 1% as dense as us and mostly made up of Sio two.
So wow.
Habitats need to be pressurized and filled with an artificial atmosphere made of
nitrogen and oxygen,
which comes with more problems,
corners,
and flat walls and weak points.
So the habitats,
we'll have rounded and smooth shapes to handle the stress of great pressure
differences between the interior and exterior.
The airlocks need to be very antisocial and work perfectly every time without an
extensive mag nitas fail or a dense atmosphere,
half of all radiation coming from space reaches the ground.
A person on the surface would be subjected to 50 times the radiation that they
would be on earth.
Three years on the surface of Mars exceeds the radiation dose limits imposed on
NASA astronauts for their entire career.
This increases cancer risks significantly.
To prevent that.
We could shield our habitats with a thick layer of frozen CO2 that can be
harvested directly from the atmosphere.
Covering the dry ice with a meter of dirt would further increase the level of
protection.
Sadly,
this means almost no windows from the inside.
Most living spaces will be window.
This tunnels from the outside,
they'll look like burial mounds.
All of this would still not hold back all the radiation,
but reduce it just enough to be survivable for long periods of time.
It won't,
however,
protect anyone who ventures outside.
So remote controlled robots we use for routine work on the surface while our
crew stays in sight.
Staying inside is a good idea.
For another reason,
Mazda dust,
it's much finer than dust on earth so it could find its way into the gears or
electronics of our machines because it's also very dry.
It's electrostatically charged,
sticking to everything like spacesuits.
It will be impossible to avoid carrying.
Lots of Mazda asked into our habitats and into the lungs of our crew to make
this even worse.
Mars,
his sword is filled with very toxic perchlorate salts.
Constant exposure could be deadly.
This problem can still be overcome though space suits,
for example,
could be made in a way that they never truly entered the base,
but stay attached to the outside of the habitats.
Okay,
great.
Now we've safety isolated humans in terms of energy and air and protected them
from cancer.
We just need to feed them water.
Is it easy to come by if a settlement is positioned near the Martian poles,
but they're thick layers of ice?
Growing food is a different kind of challenge though Mazda's soils are alkaline
and let the vital nitrogen compounds that plants need to grow before we can grow
anything.
We will have to decontaminate the soil,
which is difficult and expensive.
Then this all can be fertilized using recycled biological waste.
All of this will take a lot of time and is very energy intensive,
so we might use aquaponics to raise fish and plants together,
making the astronauts diets more varied and tasty at the same time.
This will be an important psychological boost for our overworked crew.
All of these things don't solve one fundamental problem though.
Mars has only 38% of earth's surface gravity,
which could cause muscle wasting bone loss and cardiovascular problems.
While this might be solved in the future by setting up rotating living spaces
for now,
our crew has to live with low gravity and exercise a lot to slow the degradation
down the cruise.
We'll probably have to rotate every few years after being stuck in doors,
in tight spaces without windows,
with the same people performing the same routines day in,
day out with little contact from the outside world and a lot to worry about like
Antarctic scientists or submarine staff,
they will undergo intense psychological screening to make sure they're mentally
resilient enough to handle this lifestyle for several years.
Establishing the first real infrastructure on Mars,
we'll be extremely taxing work that only a group of very determined and
competent people can do.
Luckily we have enough of these on earth and there you have it,
a small Mars base that will survive for at least a few decades as long as it's
getting eight constant supply of resources,
parts,
nuclear fuel and cruise from Earth.
Unfortunately,
Mars and earth are separated by millions of kilometers and orbital periods that
leave only a narrow travel window every two years.
If there's an emergency in the colony,
earth wouldn't be able to help until the next travel window opens.
Helpers may arrive on a planet filled with carbs is settling bars.
That will be the toughest challenge we have ever faced.
It will be gruesome work to establish the infrastructure we need,
but we're stubborn and we like extreme challenges.
If we pushed through phase two of colonization,
anything is possible.
Cities illuminating the dark Martian night,
the hub,
the travel between the planets,
industries,
setting foot in all ways.
Terraforming a true multiplanetary future.
Going to Mars is hard but worth it and if we're lucky,
we might be around long enough to see it happening and cheer on the people who
take on these challenges for the benefit of a soul.
Figuring out complex stuff is one of the best feelings ever,
especially if you don't have to do it all by yourself.
Our friends from brilliant can help you out with that part.
Brilliant is a problem solving website with a hands on approach.
Instead of just dropping tricky concepts in front of you,
they help you unravel them bit by bit and build up to an interesting conclusion.
This way science becomes something you actually do actively and not only hear
about with brilliant,
you can bet down on dozens of interesting causes and puzzles about topics like
soda,
Angie gravity and astronomy.
If you visit brilliant.org/not shell or click the link in the description,
you can sign up for free and learn all kinds of things.
And as a bonus for courts cause aren't viewers the first at 688 people will also
get 20% off that and your membership with brilliance,
you finish your day a little bit smarter and no Mars dust to deal with.
We promise can't get enough of Mars.
We've also a poster about it.
You could learn some more about the hardships of Mars colonization or just look
at the pretty colors.
Go get it here.